last time I did a run of guest videos we
had an enthusiastic young presenter
talking about food signs and backing it
up with an experiment well we are doing
it again
Alex from technicality studios it's all
yours
this is Splenda it's known as a zero
calorie sweetener or a healthy
replacement for sugar Splenda no calorie
sweetener with the original sugar light
taste in love and trust but hold up wait
a minute how is this even possible have
you ever thought to yourself it's a
little strange that a food has zero
calories can it even have that well yes
it's theoretically possible think of it
this way if you say eat plastic nothing
really will happen plastic has zero
usable calories if you eat it you can't
take energy from it don't eat plastic by
the way this is just an example so
before our answering how many calories
Splenda really has if any we first have
to answer if Splenda has any usable
calories at all how do we do that
well when we eat and digest sugar or
sucrose our body turns it into glucose
and fructose fructose is delivered to
your liver and promptly turned into
glucose and glucose as the stuff your
body uses as energy to find out if
there's any calories in this pack of a
Splenda we have to find out if there's
any glucose in this packet of Splenda
and finding that's easy or at least it
seemed easy after my chemistry teacher
explained it to me like 20 times we'll
do two experiments for the first
experiment the control test will
dissolve 0.2 grams of sugar and point 1
grams of an enzyme called invertase and
water enzymes are things that speed up
chemical reactions or catalysts thus the
enzyme will quickly break down sugar
into glucose and fructose in the second
experiment we'll use the exact same
procedure but change one material
instead of using sugar
we'll use Splenda let's go to the lab
now that we've gathered all the
materials let's get started Noda future
editing so this is Splenda this is sugar
so now I'm going to dissolve both of
those things in water in these things
test tubes
now that we've dissolved everything in
the test tube but let's put them in a
warm water bath like this for 20 minutes
the water should be about 37 degrees
Celsius for body temperature this is the
best temperature for the enzymes after
letting it sit for 20 minutes I'm going
to put in Benedict's solution Benedict's
solution will tell us if there's glucose
in these test tubes Benedict's solution
is named after Stanley Rossiter
Benedict's an American chemist and not
Benedict Cumberbatch a British actor
this is a disappointment it's now time
to goggle
up now when we put in the Benedict's
solution we're gonna replace the
37-degree water with boiling water then
let's add in a few drops and weight from
the Benedict's solution to do its thing
so I just learned that how Benedict's
solution works is basically it's a
spectrum right so blue would be the
least amount of glucose no glucose and
then there's red which would be the most
amount of glucose that's a lot of
glucose now as you can see these two are
basically kind of orange caramel colored
but the one in the Splenda solution
actually is a little darker and a little
more intense if you look really closely
so that means there's actually more
glucose in the Splenda than the actual
sugar isn't that crazy I mean I was
blown away
Splenda which is marketed as a zero
calorie alternative to sugar actually
has more glucose than actual sugar why
well splendas most using gradient is
dextrose you know that is a fancy word
for glucose so how many calories are in
these packets for four calories how do
we know that well I emailed Splenda
customer service and they wrote back
that there are four calories in each
single cert packet of Splenda no calorie
sweetener because that makes sense
side note here one gram of sugar has
four calories and each packet of Splenda
is about a gram hmm wait a sec if each
packet has four calories why Splenda
allowed to say they have none that seems
pretty sketchy
it might seem sketchy but it's
completely legal the Food and Drug
Administration allows foods with fewer
and 5 calories per serving to be
marketed as having zero calories down to
the nutrition label that means you can't
trust any food that claims it has zero
calories well now you know until next
time thank you so very much for watching
thank you to Tom for giving me the pill
if you're making a guest video thank you
to my chemistry teacher for staying late
and helping me with every little
annoying thing I asked for
dftba and explore on go subscribe
products his channel let's be honest
he's gonna have my job in a few years so
you're just getting in early that is it
for this one of guest videos thank you
very much for watching thank you to all
the presenters I'll be back next time
and until then I will see you on the
Internet